Do you have a favorite pair of pjs?
So cozy that you wear them for more than a
few nights in a row?
You disgust me!
Hey guys, Julia here for DNews
A recent survey by Ergoplex polled 2,500 young
adult couples about their pajama habits and
they found surprisingly gross answers.
Most people wear the same PJS for more than
two weeks at a time.
But men and women had slightly reasons for
their lazy loungewear habits.
73% of men complained that someone else did
the laundry, so they didn’t have any control.
Women said they switched between a few pairs
of pjs, so it was hard to remember how long
they’d be wearing them for.
Both men and women do the old fashioned sniff
test.
50% of men and 41% of women say their pjs
don’t smell bad, so why bother changing
them?
I mean, no one sees them, they don’t smell
that bad? so why do we need to bother?
Well in a word, bacteria.
Our body is crawling with bacteria.
We carry about three to five pounds of it
in and on us.
Our skin and intestines are kind of like their
own ecosystems.
One study found 1,400 different strains of
bacteria, JUST IN THE BELLY BUTTON.
Most of this bacteria is alright, it can be
pretty good for us.
Some protect us from the outside world or
helps us digest things we couldn’t on our
own.
But bacteria build up can do a lot of harm.
In the oily parts of the body, called sebaceous
sites, like our head and face, the build of
a bacterial species P. acnes, causes, you
guessed it, acne.
We all carry harmless strains of E. Coli in
our guts, but if they get where they’re
not supposed to be, like in the urinary tract,
it can cause infection.
There’s also a risk of getting staphylococcus
bacteria which, into cuts can cause serious
infections.
Our body is constantly shedding skin cells,
constantly.
We slough off a more than a few skin cells,
30 to 40 thousand cells fall off an hour.
As we spend a third of our lives asleep, that’s
a lot of time to shed some cells.
If you don’t wash your pjs for at least
two weeks, washing them only once might spread
these microbes and skins cells to the rest
of your laundry!
Dirty pjs are nothing to shake a sheet at.
Speaking of sheets, how often do you change
yours?
A fifth of responders to a recent survey say
it’s not even once a month.
Dust mites are more than happy with this arrangement.
They love to nibble on your dead skin cells.
So much so, I bet right now, your mattress
and pillows are FILLED with the little critters.
Old mattresses might have up to ten million
of them crawling around.
And after two years, about ten percent of
a pillow’s weight might be dust mites and
their poo.
Around 20 million Americans, are allergic
to dust mite poo, which can cause annoying
rashes and asthma.
So please go wash your pjs and sheets at least
every two weeks.
Change your pillows every six months.
And you’ll be sleeping sweet and clean.
Alright guys, time to admit, how long do you
go in the same pair of pjs?
Let us know in the comments below and don’t
forget to hit that subscribe button, we bring
more science news to you every day.